people tend to attach lots of meaning to
failure now for sure can tell this about
myself so if I fail often associate with
it that was because I wasn't good enough
if I failed it's because I haven't
worked hard enough if I fail it's
because something bad about myself but
the truth is failure means nothing let
this sink in guys failure has no meaning
at all failure has only the meaning that
you attach to it so yes maybe you did
fail at something but so what right what
does this really say about you what does
this say about anything it's in your
hand what meaning you attach to failure
lots of successful people fail all the
time